people
of the internet that's a wrecking tour
here and we are back with another
episode of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
you can see we're getting ready for the
first quidditch match
gryffindor versus slytherin
gryffindor's new team seeker is harry
potter
not sure no favoritism
it's okay jordan it's okay guys if
we are meeting and or you're checking
out the channel for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell we post videos
every week here on youtube if you guys
enjoy this video today make sure you hit
that like button
and if you'd like to hang out here more
in the future then don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell so you
don't miss any of our new videos oh my
goodness i forgot the controls are so
weird on this
here got the gryffindor speaker no the
snitch got away
no the switch got away okay wait so i
have to pass through so many
guys this is so i promise
it's harder than it looks maybe i need
to plug in a controller
i'm trying to use w a s and d like
you can't use the mouse to steer it see
as soon as i start using the mouse
everything goes haywire
and shift does make him go faster
what is that little chart down there at
the bottom
oh dude this this slytherin secret like
he is dominating me man
he is dominating me
i'm right on it dude i'm right on it let
me grab it yes i see it
[Music]
how is he not grabbing that i think you
have to like build up the meter first
otherwise you could just like end these
games really fast
yeah i don't even know if i have to pay
attention to those rings wait press the
jump button
yes let's go in chat gryffindor
i don't know what's going on with the
audio here
oh my goodness my name's lee jordan
signing off like what's the score 160.
we caught that so quick you guys are
like retro you were terrible dude you
were terrible
i was at the beginning a little bit of a
learning curve there
trying to use my my left hand on w a
s and d to steer harry and then shift to
make him go faster
if hogwarts had won the quidditch match
that's right we did that's right we did
oh defense against the dark arts
again for winning the quidditch match
against slytherin you are fantastic
something is troubling me harry oh it's
troubling i had strange noises outside
the forbidden corridor
come up to the third floor and have a
look no way
wait is this troll in the dungeon is
this troll in the dungeon
is that ron just put in the daily profit
that gringott
has been broken into i wonder who'd do
that
i know who would do that
[Music]
wait why are they all like congregating
down there though what's going on
okay i guess nothing
if it's the troll which is what i'm
thinking then it should mean that
they're
at the uh halloween feast can we cast
on this statue again no last time we saw
it let us cast lopindo on there to uh
get even more birdie bob beans out of it
okay i i guys i don't know where he told
me to go
is that her i think that's her
hey friend george
wait are they the noises our friend
george causing the noises
wait is this actually like a little bit
of a free room here can i can i
just go around the castle wherever i
want
this obviously it wouldn't let me go
that one direction that i was trying to
moments ago
but let's see
[Music]
it gives me the creeps yeah i mean i can
see why
hello hufflepuff there are secrets
everywhere in hogwarts
really well well see i played this game
at such a young age
originally guys the other day
i played it at such a young age that i
really didn't
know how to fully explore and look for
all the little hidden secrets and things
like that
but yeah i mean i i feel like the game
is actually opened up a bit here
[Music]
to where i can just freely explore
and i do not remember that wow two
birdie about beans
come on now out for the venomous
tentaculous in the greenhouse oh
they are dangerous they are indeed let
me tell you
let me tell you we've had our share of
run-ins with them
okay i don't want to go too far in here
because
can i castle pindo on any of these
it doesn't look like it
[Music]
you're quite tenacious aren't you oh
yeah we're tenacious
the heck why is he asking me that are
you tenacious
[Music]
about to say that bookshelf right there
looks like
a hidden hidden area for sure whoa what
is this i need to bring it back up
because
i don't think i can just fall down guys
i do not remember this at all
i played it at such a young age i just
like went straight through and did the
basic stuff
now it is also entirely possible that i
do remember
that i did do all this and i've just
forgotten it it's been so long since i
played this game
all right so again that's probably my
biggest critique of the game is that
there's not more collectibles it's
just birdy bop beans and the wizard
cards
the wizard cards are cool thumbs up on
there and honestly the birdie bop beans
i love to give them a hard time
because there's so many they're fine on
their own it's just the fact that that's
all you get in
so many of the chests
now again it's been so long since i
played maybe we're gonna be able to
redeem those beans for something
really cool from fred and george
there we go two more beans 253
[Music]
another single bean right there
i don't think i want to save just yet
alhamora on the statue let's go
dude
all right more more beans well if we can
buy something
cool with the beans then we are going to
be
stocked up we've collected so many beans
at this point oh goodness
these guys will try to take them i
cannot allow that to happen
we cannot allow these gnomes to do that
[Music]
that's right stun all of them with findo
aloha more on the chest and what do we
have a lot of birdie bop beans
[Music]
oh one's back up
or did i just miss him
[Music]
oh i can't break these is this room
really just for you to collect a couple
of more beans
like see like they were on the right
track they were totally on the right
track with this game i love that there's
these hidden areas you can find and
explore
but the fact that this was just a room
for a couple more beans
come on man wait secret passage
ah i was hopeful
it's all good though it's all good i
wonder when peeves is gonna show up
again
it's been a while it's been a little bit
since we've seen peeves
i feel like he is always lurking in this
game
those gnomes are pesky little things
aren't they they are dude
they are incredibly pesky little things
wait can i go
that's where i'm supposed to meet
hermione on the third floor
i'm just gonna go this way first
and also what where did fred and george
go
i feel like i was supposed to follow
them and then it just started yeah
chocolate frog i just started exploring
a lot of random stuff
[Music]
okay
watch it's going to be for more beans
[Music]
oh a secret passage secret passage
come on wizard card give us a wizard
card and not birdie
come on come on come on oh my goodness
[Music]
well if you like birdie bot beans then
this is the game
for you oh what is going on
[Music]
i thought sirius black was gonna appear
in the fire
25 oh fred and george like
trust me dude he's the one with the
wizard god oh is your card okay thanks
harry
we really needed this plenty more where
those came from we're playing on
slytherin
plenty more
let me know i think i already have this
guy that's newt right
pretty sure that's newt's commander
which doesn't look anything like what we
know of newton to be now but
i'm almost positive that's let's see
go into our folio magi oh no birdie bot
wow so we don't get more bernie bob
beans
instead we get the birdie bot wizard
card there's newt's commander though you
see why i got him confused
birdie bot holding a little birdie bop
bag
of every flavor beans
eighteen ninety so wait what what are
the dates on pretty bought
1935 so don't expect to see
birdie bop beans in hogwarts legacy
because they hadn't been invented yet
all right can i like take the secret
passage
how do you guys do that you gotta teach
me your tricks fred and george
teach me all your little tricks
okay we don't need to go over there
i do believe we could check check down
this area
isn't it funny how none of the students
react
to harry like running around just
casting spells on
breaking faces how great would it be if
snape just appears
potter you don't want me as your enemy
just takes you to dumbledore's office
because you're destroying you're
destroying all these random pots around
the
around the school give me more bird
about bees give me more bread about
beans
oh we can get up there i don't know why
though maybe it's a secret passage
and will this door open
maybe alamora on it
okay all right i thought they were about
to be stuck for a second
you're really gonna keep me from being
able to get some of those beans
okay i may have already been in this
area i have no idea
all right let's jump up here see if
there's anything anything extra we can
do up here
i think it's so weird when the music
just goes out like that i don't know if
it's because i'm playing this on
windows 10 and there's a bunch of hoops
you have to jump through to even get it
set up and working but or if it's just
like little random
random glitches that were originally
part of the game
okay so we checked out that area
we tried to go in there we couldn't go
in there
we need to get back to the those stairs
and go up to see hermione
she's on the third floor
i think this is the right way yeah i've
gotten
all turned around now
i am so bad with directions you guys i
mean
really like in real life i'm bad and in
games i'm bad
okay some slytherin please stop that
what
i'm just saying hi please stop that okay
slytherin
gonna be that way fine see you guys i
mean
all you slytherins out there so it
really does
it connects all the way around nice
because this is where we started out we
went this way at the beginning
all right so we just need to navigate
back up to the spot where
uh that look that girl is like the third
floor is this way
the third floor is up these stairs at
least it was yesterday
wait this floor right these stairs right
here okay
i'm trusting this dude
no he's wrong it's not this way is it
you really do have a lightning bolt scar
on your forehead
that's right yes i do
oh wait this is what we already did
please stop that
oh my goodness these slytherins man
please stop that here it is
and by here it is no i'm wrong i'm
totally wrong
i'm totally wrong
see here's the part where you guys are
oh there there there there
yes okay we're good i was just about to
say here's the part where you guys are
gonna see a little fade out
as i transition and pretend that it
didn't take me forever to find that
no we'll keep it rolling keep the
cameras rolling
all right harry i think hermione's up
here i don't know if it's the troll
or if she hears fluffy
and he's limping he's limping
bro i don't know about the snape guy you
guys think he's good or bad
did you see that where'd you come from
came out of the forbidden corridor
he's living quite badly come on harry
let's take a look before filch comes
back
all right hear that growling
i think there's something awful down the
corridor you think
it's not creepy at all not creepy at all
[Music]
tell me on the right thanks for leaving
his hands for our defense against dark
arts lesson
all right let's do it vince gets the
dark arts coming up
okay oh just conveniently it's right
there
it's right there right where fluffy we
learned to illuminate
the hawk magic
gonna take it nice and slow the first
time because the first one you don't
have to get a great score on
it's the really the last one where you
really have to speed it up
all right that should be at least 90
94 okay all right so this time we're
gonna go a little bit faster
the house with the most points at the
end of the year
wins the house okay quirrell yep you
mentioned
you mentioned that in the first couple
lessons try working faster this time mr
potter
faster quarrel you got it
oh messed up a little bit there
86 okay so it was a worse score than our
first one we did go a lot faster
done mr potter ten
points ten points i think we have to do
it again
let's see what you can do because i know
there's for sure a twenty point one
i think it's weird that they have lumos
illuminates dark magic points for
gryffindor instead of just being like
the light try again mr potter
try again okay you got this oh i messed
up badly
i was scratching my arm i promise uh
we're definitely not getting 95 are we
wow i i honestly can't believe it even
got 90
bucks close but not the correct shape
okay whatever quarterly got voldemort in
the back of your head anyway dude
your points mean nothing to me they mean
nothing
you may begin the loomis challenge to
practice the spell
[Music]
follow me mr papata see another
challenge star
hold down the mouse button to aim the
spell
to cast lumos let go of the button
all right you made come on
gargoyle
quite bright isn't it oh that's cool you
can
cross like not at all what this spell is
supposed to do guys
if any of you are for some reason
watching this video and you're not like
a harry potter fan
which if you're not a harry potter fan
why would you believe that on the statue
okay
expose the correct path all right calm
down quirrell
gotta dude but yeah lumos is just
basically like a flashlight for wizards
makes their one light up
but i don't know i mean it's it's kind
of a cool mechanic
i just wish they'd uh maybe use a
different spell other than lumos
all right we got a save game book up
there up to 260
beans right now i wish you could just
cash them all in next time i see fred
george be like look guys
just give me all the wizard cards you
got
because uh i got plenty of beans
let me tell you okay
that's probably going to open that down
and
there's gonna open that all right which
side should we start with here let's
start with
we'll try this way first i don't know if
it matters or if you actually do need to
go in a certain order but
let's start with this one here oh you
guys know i'm getting my
lone birdie button
dude this gargle is kind of creepy
now does that stay i wonder do those
stay
or is it like timed
[Music]
okay i think they stay right
can he grab on yes he can
excellent
grab on here grab on there
and make it all the way nicely done
harry are you serious
wait what wait what it was just a trial
run
oh come on oh come on
don't do me like that oh
we were supposed to go and order chat
we were supposed to go in order
i'm so used to streaming on twitch that
i just say chat even though this is
actually a youtube
only this exclusive for you guys
watching on youtube i did not live
stream this
try to experiment a little bit with uh
with streaming it
versus just doing the let's play style
like this where i just record the
gameplay
let me guys know in the comments if you
have a preference or if you like it one
way or another
i'm kind of experimenting i enjoy both i
love i love streaming
but i also feel like this lets me kind
of connect with the youtube audience
in a different way
leap of faith all right there we go
another challenge star
[Music]
what's up right here collect more betty
bought beans
and almost on the gargoyle
all right we're gonna hit the save game
book such a weird spot for the like why
not put the why not have that save game
book
over here wait what
can i make that jump can he
no way harry cannot jump that high
for that far rather or can he
i thought maybe i had to like shoot
maybe there's another gargoyle hidden
like i have to flip into
hold on let's back up
now maybe it's just that i can't tell
like where it actually
ends the platform
okay let's all right we're going for it
oh of course he can't make that dude now
why is this one down here
what is going on
okay guys so that was
pretty alarming what i had to do uh
pause the gameplay for a bit there and i
had to go online and search apparently
this is a glitch this is indeed
a known glitch fortunately there are
harry potter cheat codes that actually
enable a
super jump so what i did i wasn't even
streaming when i did this i wish i had
been
or recording rather but uh there's a
code you just type in harry super jump
and he makes like this super big leap
and it was actually enough to get me up
here so
thankfully i did manage to cross the
chasm
guys i think that will be where we pause
for today thank you all so much for
watching make sure you leave me some
comments down below let me know what you
think about this format if you enjoyed
it
give it a thumbs up don't forget to
subscribe as always guys thank you so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon